Janie Pacino a passé huit ans dans un
pensionnat à Fort George James
Bay,
mais il a fallu 70 ans et la découverte
de possibles tombes anonymes à Kamloops
pour qu'elle s'ouvre enfin sur son
expérience
quand j'ai entendu parler de la découverte en Colombie-Britannique
quelque chose qui s'est passé quelque chose s'est cassé
et les chambres ont refait surface J'avais vu des
enfants se faire gifler avant jamais
jamais comme ça jamais aussi violent Je
ne comprenais pas la mort à l'époque
au 215 où nous avons commencé à nous approcher
et il a dit oh souviens-toi de ce qui s'est passé alors
je pense que ça a ouvert un  beaucoup d'
yeux
[Musique]
sur la base de ces témoignages et plus encore les
cris de la Baie James entreprendront des
recherches au sol autour de deux anciens
pensionnats, une tâche ardue qui ne
révélera qu'une partie de ce qui est arrivé aux
enfants autochtones décédés dans le système des pensionnats du Québec,
mais il  il y a plus d'enfants qui ont été
déplacés et des
enfants déportés nous sommes allés à la recherche de
[Musique]
ça veut dire Great River
c'est le point le plus au nord  à Québec
accessible par la
route à quelques kilomètres de là le traversier
mène à l'île de Fort George où
les deux premiers pensionnats au
Québec ont été construits dans les années 1930
Janie Pacino a fréquenté le pensionnat Saint Phillips the
Anglican pendant près d'une
décennie comme sa mère avant elle  qui
faisait partie de la première classe d'enfants
envoyés là-bas,
elle est très en colère
parce qu'elle avait 12 ans et qu'elle avait l'habitude d'
être sur la terre
personne n'avait jamais vu un
pensionnat ou vécu dans un
et elle ne voulait pas y aller  mais elle n'avait pas le
choix, la
fréquentation des pensionnats était
obligatoire pour les enfants autochtones
et elle me parlait une fois
de travailler dans la cuisine et
la nourriture qu'on leur demandait de cuisiner
avait des asticots partout et on leur a
dit de ne pas les enlever pour  les mettre dans
la marmite et
donc c'est ce qu'ils ont eu à manger
[Musique]
petite et inconsciente de l'expérience de sa mère
Janie rêvait d'aller à l'
école
une de mes cousines est revenue
sa première année  et elle avait cette
robe à carreaux brillante et des chaussures noires brillantes et
oh je veux ressembler à ça aussi
mais surtout elle voulait apprendre
qu'elle aussi découvrirait la dure réalité
des pensionnats indiens
on nous rappelait constamment que
nous étions des sauvages  t des
païens sauvages ignorants
et si nous ne nous formions pas, il n'y avait pas
d'espoir pour nous, nous avons pu y croire au
bout d'un moment
et récemment, le pire des souvenirs a
refait surface à 10 ans, l'enfant a
failli mourir sous ses yeux
et la première chose que j'ai  J'ai pensé à l'
histoire de la fille que j'ai racontée
et même maintenant quand j'y
pense
je me suis rendu compte que je ne m'en suis toujours pas
remis
c'est une histoire qui va prendre du
temps à Janie pour lui raconter
son témoignage et celui des autres a
finalement convaincu les cris  de chasibi pour
entreprendre des recherches au sol
les survivants veulent que nous allions de l'avant ils
connaissent les activités pouvant être demandées ils
veulent que nous recherchions des zones spécifiques
mais par où commencer les
archives disponibles sont au mieux incomplètes ils
révèlent rec  problèmes financiers actuels et
listes d'enfants malades beaucoup d'
enfants malades certains admis dans des
pensionnats avec la tuberculose
mais les archives ne font aucune mention de l'
endroit où les enfants peuvent être enterrés
euh
étranger
fait partie d'un groupe de survivants
recueillant des histoires des aînés de sa communauté
il avait six ans  ans quand il
est entré pour la première fois à Saint Phillips,
nous avons tous eu le mal du pays au bout d'un moment.
Musique]
l'histoire de Fort George est unique au
Canada les catholiques et les anglicans ont concouru
pour les étudiants pour les convertir, mais
principalement pour les subventions gouvernementales
qu'ils ont fournies les enfants ont été amenés
d'aussi loin que mishtuyatz à mille
kilomètres de là de nombreuses histoires troublantes
proviennent du pensionnat
catholique  à l'extérieur du village
il y avait un sous-sol et euh
il n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas de sol en béton
donc c'était  juste un sol en terre battue
étranger,
le bâtiment n'existe plus, mais de
nombreuses histoires ont fait surface sur les
secrets éventuellement enfouis dans son sous
-sol juste une histoire que j'ai entendu dire qu'ils ont
vu quelqu'un voir des croix là-dedans des gens
apportant des fleurs là-bas
alors ils ont supposé qu'ils étaient cimetières
Des tombes donc mais si t'as cinq six
ans tu saisis pas vraiment tout
c'est seulement plus tard que quand tu
repenses et dis oh peut être que c'est arrivé à l'
étranger
de l'institution catholique il ne
reste aujourd'hui qu'un cimetière peut être
celui de l'infirmerie deux  rangées de
croix environ 20 noms dont nous savons
peu de choses
mais il pourrait y avoir plus de lieux de sépulture
Selon certains anciens
[Musique]
il a dit qu'il y avait une épidémie une fois
et vous devriez vraiment vérifier J'ai entendu dire
qu'il y avait une tombe quelque part comme là où
ils ont mis  tous comme une tombe comme une
fosse commune
16 décès confirmés à Fort George six
de l'école catholique 10 des
anglicans
[Musique]
les témoignages peuvent conduire à plus
découvertes déjà cinq sites potentiels
ont été identifiés sur l'île pour
des recherches au sol
s'ajoutent les hôpitaux fédéraux pour
les Inuits et les deux écoles de Fort
George quatre autres pensionnats
ont été construits au Québec dès les années 1950
maliute
[Musique]
et accrochons
ailleurs au pays des appels avaient
commencé pour l'abolition des
pensionnats mais au Québec les églises faisaient
encore campagne pour les construire
coûte que coûte
détection
les enfants n'étaient pas épargnés les
abus physiques sexuels et psychologiques mais
cela aurait été rare
car
[Musique]
mais la récente  les découvertes à Kamloops
ont semé le doute des
discussions sont en cours à travers le Québec
sur la nécessité d'entreprendre des recherches
sur le terrain pour trouver la vérité
[Musique]
mais une autre question se pose et si des
enfants du Québec étaient enterrés
ailleurs dans d'autres provinces
[Musique]
le nombre d'enfants autochtones envoyés
à  Les foyers fédéraux et
pensionnats au Québec sont estimés à 13 000
mais plusieurs  plus gonflé dans les rangs des
écoles d'autres provinces, en particulier en
Ontario
[Musique]
Kenneth whisky se souvient du moment où il a
été arraché à sa famille à West
Kaganish et envoyé dans le nord de l'Ontario,
le gouvernement est arrivé avec tous ces
avions affrétés que nous appelons tout construire
ces assiettes et j'ai emmené
tous les enfants de la communauté dans
différents pensionnats.
J'étais le programme scolaire pour ces
enfants de cinq six ans,
vous savez, je suis entré pour la première fois. J'étais à la
maternelle
et je ne savais pas ce qui se passait
et il  n'était pas seul
et à la pointe sud de la baie James, la
colonie de moose Factory
[Music] à
travers les trois
crée principalement des enfants de moose
Factory ou Sky English nemska East Main
weimanji et Sassy Greek children ils
ont tous été envoyés à des
enfants cris respectés ont été envoyés  jusqu'au shinwak de Moose Factory
et jusqu'à Brantford des
enfants anishnabi et abineki, nous avons envoyé à
travers l'Ontario du magma et des malasites jusqu'en
Nouvelle-Écosse, mais la première vague de
les enfants déportés venaient de la
région de Montréal
tu es
idiot plus
Tisdale est un chercheur Mohawk Inu, il a
parcouru les registres obscurs du recensement et a trouvé
trois autres vagues d'enfants de
kanawaki kanisateki et aquasazane
déportés jusqu'au siècle suivant, tous
envoyés dans des institutions où la vie était
souvent difficile
[Musique  ]
Industries
le taux de mortalité était cinq fois plus élevé
que dans la population générale
à shinwak seulement le registre des décès
contient les noms d'au moins sept
enfants des mohawks du Québec pour la
plupart
et le processus d'identification est
toujours en cours est
Raymond fragner est l'archiviste en chef
pour le Centre national pour la vérité et la
réconciliation c'est son travail de compléter
les archives de la commission dont le
mandat s'est terminé en 2015. les
documents historiques du Québec sont limités et
posent un défi unique vivant parmi l'
église
nous avons obtenu une copie du seul rapport
hors du Québec  produit pour la
Commission en 2012.
ce n'est qu'un aperçu de la réalité
à laquelle  par des enfants dans les pensionnats du Québec
et il n'a pas encore été publié
Québec est
le rapport démontre que beaucoup plus
pourrait être tiré des Archives
par exemple cette histoire d'un
enfant abineki du Québec en route vers Chapel et les
pensionnats shinwak il y avait
16 survivants il  dit que nous avions 37 ans mais certains sont
morts,
ce qui remet en question le décompte officiel du Québec
Ries
et ses frères et sœurs ont passé des années dans des
pensionnats en Ontario et l'un
d'eux n'est jamais rentré
beaucoup Je vois le Met
un
Italien
dit que la voleuse
Emma saganash était une pionnière à la radio de CBC
et la télévision en langue crie,
elle et ses 10 frères et sœurs ont été
forcés de quitter leur village de
waswanipi au Québec, ils ont tous été envoyés
dans différentes institutions à travers l'Ontario
dans les années 50 et 60
Usine
notre école Bishop Gordon
Jane Louisiana
Brantford siège de l'Institut Mohawk
est le plus ancien pensionnat au
Canada à l'
étranger une centaine d'enfants sont morts à
Brentford la communauté a begu  Dans la
recherche de tombes non marquées dans
notre système,
la famille Saiganesh a longtemps cherché
le lieu de sépulture de leur aîné John,
c'est la seule photo de lui à six
ans, il a été enlevé à ses parents
et mis dans un avion vers une destination inconnue.
John est arrivé à  Moose Factory en 1954.
il est mort plusieurs mois plus tard sa famille
n'a jamais su comment ni où il avait été
enterré
étranger
[Musique]
[
Musique]  Je me
tiens là où le plus grand ouais
merci
[Musique]
euh
la
pensée étrangère c'était la fin de l'histoire
mais après les découvertes à Kamloops, un
ancien élève du pensionnat a
proposé une version différente des
événements
Earthly
beautiful
mon amitié
John est maintenant sur la liste des victimes pas
au Québec mais en
Ontario on ne sait pas combien d'enfants ont été
déportés ni combien ne sont jamais revenus
e construites dans les années 1960
[Musique]
ces archives rares nous permettent d'
entrevoir le quotidien des
enfants des pensionnats québécois mais on sait
maintenant que de nombreux sombres secrets se cachaient
derrière les images souriantes pas étonnant
donc que la découverte de
sépultures anonymes dans le reste  du Canada a amené de
nombreuses communautés à envisager des
recherches au sol ici au Québec en mystérieux
officiellement il n'y a pas de décès mais nous avons
trouvé le cas d'au moins un enfant
transféré à l'hôpital de raberval
où il serait décédé
il y aurait d'autres cas similaires
étrangers
il pourrait être douloureux  découvertes
autour d'anciens sanatoriums le
Centre national pour la vérité et la réconciliation a
confirmé qu'un tel institut dans la
région de Montréal fait l'objet de recherches en ce
moment
ou plus
parce que le Québec avait moins de
pensionnats et que ses écoles ont été construites plus
tard et donc les tombes non marquées seraient
plus rares
où officiellement il n'y a qu'un seul décès les
consultations n'ont pas donné lieu à de nouvelles
découvertes  ies la communauté ne
considère pas les recherches au sol nécessaires
latsuk ne compte également qu'un seul décès officiel
mais le rapport non publié de la Commission vérité
et réconciliation en révèle un
deuxième
[Musique]
en 1969 lors d'une épidémie de méningite
qui a contraint l'école à la quarantaine
la communauté n'a pas encore  décider
s'il procédera à des surtensions
[Musique]
le cas de Saint Marc la figure soulève des
questions aucun enfant n'y est jamais mort
selon le registre officiel
cette photo jamais publiée auparavant
semble prouver le contraire elle montre le directeur
du pensionnat debout au-dessus d'
un  cercueil à côté d'autres étudiants
la baie d'anishina ont confirmé qu'il
manque au moins trois enfants
une recherche au sol est fort probable que
Fort George où les recherches au sol devraient
commencer l'été prochain sera la première
communauté au Québec à tester ses
soupçons
nous reconnaissons que cela sera douloureux
il  est douloureux de ne pas savoir
et il sera douloureux d'apprendre la
vérité
le travail prendra  deux à trois ans
et promet d'être complexe en raison du
terrain accidenté et de la végétation qui
a reconquis la terre
où ils se trouvent une terre sacrée
c'est à nous de le bénir dans leurs
mémoires
[Musique]
le pensionnat est là-bas
au  l'âge de sept ans Kenneth est retourné au
Québec pour fréquenter un pensionnat à
Fort George il se souvient d'un garçon qui est tombé
malade à l'école anglicane Saint
Phillips dans les années 60
devait avoir environ huit ans
peut-être
ce dont je me souviens quand je suis ici d'
accord il  décédé ici dans ce
pensionnat parce qu'il avait très froid
Chevrolet
son nom n'apparaît pas sur la liste officielle à
travers des témoignages en recherchant
des archives d'articles et des documents historiques
nous avons identifié quatre cas non comptabilisés
à Saint Phillips
et huit autres au
pensionnat catholique
tué de nombreux enfants  dans les premières années
selon un historien avec les
questions des religieuses grises
est parmi les derniers survivants
qui peuvent encore témoigner t  le souvenir
qui la hante est celui d'Ellen bobish
étrangère
et après chaque repas nous étions censés
sortir immédiatement
elle était assise là
par terre et je suis entré dans la
salle de jeux elle avait les jambes sur les genoux se
tenant comme ça avec sa tête
sur  ses genoux
le superviseur est entré
et a commencé à lui crier de
se lever s'habiller va dehors
elle a dit je ne peux pas
j'ai dit je t'ai dit de te lever tu sais va
dehors je ne peux pas je suis malade je suis allé la voir et j'ai
commencé à lui donner des coups de pied  le côté
et elle est en quelque sorte allée comme ça et
lui donnait des coups de pied dans le dos et elle a finalement continué à glisser vers la porte et l'a finalement donné un coup de pied à l'extérieur la fille était
allongée là en position fœtale et
c'était en février
et il fait très froid dehors  Février
ici,
quelques jours plus tard,
ils ont annoncé qu'elle était décédée et
il a dit ne parlez pas de cela, elle est
partie,
n'en parlez plus
[Musique]
chaque nouveau cas potentiel que nous avons
trouvé nécessitera une recherche scrupuleuse avant d'
être confirmé et  ajouté à la
liste officielle
mais beaucoup pointe vers une liste révisée et mise à jour
des victimes des pensionnats
au Québec
si les recherches mènent à de nouvelles découvertes
les prochaines étapes pourraient s'avérer difficiles
c'est juste la conviction que nous avons qu'il
ne faut pas déranger les tombes une fois
qu'elles  'ai été défini si
vous allez le piétiner, vous le dérangez,
surtout si vous allez creuser
dans certaines zones où des gens ont été
enterrés, je pense que cela rend les choses très difficiles,
ils exhument les corps si c'est le cas
ils ne pourront jamais identifier les
restes c'est un autre chapitre de l'
histoire pour lequel la fin reste
non écrite
et c'est un processus qui fait appel à
la résilience des anciens élèves et des
survivants à travers la province, à la fois les Inuits
et les Premières Nations
étrangers,
vous grandissez et survivez à tous  de cela tu
ne veux pas te souvenir tu veux le
garder caché tu l'
enterre quelque part pour l'oublier mais
tu ne peux pas oublier
[Musique]
ces souvenirs impossibles à oublier
appartiennent maintenant à notre Co  histoire llective
[Musique]
vous savez
la vie de ces enfants a été prise à un
endroit où ils étaient censés être
protégés et aimés
et nous leur devons,
ainsi qu'à leurs familles et à ceux qui les aiment,
de les honorer avec la dignité
qu'ils  toujours mérité